Making a three-hour-long superhero film is
no small feat.
Co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo did an
admirable job with Avengers: Endgame, filling
the film with loads of plot without ever overwhelming
fans.
At the end of the day, it's a remarkable juggling
act.
That said, a few confusing sections passed
by without any kind of explanation, no doubt
leaving audiences with questions.
Warning: You're now entering Spoiler Country.
One of the biggest headscratchers occurred
when Thanos called members of his Black Order
and countless Chitauri from the past, bringing
them to the present for the final battle against
the Avengers.
Sure, it makes sense that he'd want to use
a huge army to take down Earth's Mightiest
Heroes.
But the movie never quite explains how Thanos
does it.
Fortunately, co-director Joe Russo is here
to explain away that particular plot hole.
Speaking to Chinese-language website QQ, Russo
discussed Thanos' use of Pym Particles to
travel into his future and battle the Avengers.
The film shows past-Nebula stealing a vial
of Pym Particles from present-Nebula.
The rare subatomic particle was discovered
by Dr. Hank Pym and subsequently handed off
to Thanos.
That explains how Thanos was able to flash-forward
a few years and face off against his foes,
but it doesn't explain how his army or his
massive ship were able to do the same.
According to Russo, this plot hole can be
pretty easily patched up.
You see, Thanos had the help of his dastardly
acolyte Ebony Maw, and they managed to replicate
the Pym Particles, making enough to bring
everyone from their present to the future
through the Quantum Realm.
Got that?
The website Comic Book Movie helpfully translated
Russo's explanation:
The story more or less checks out.
It's easy to believe Thanos and Ebony Maw
could figure out a way to duplicate the scientific
work of the super-smart, but still human Hank
Pym on a monumental scale.
Remember: Maw and Thanos both happen to be
brilliant, evil geniuses.
At the end of Avengers: Endgame, Iron Man
snatched the Infinity Stones from Thanos and
loaded them up into his own suit.
Thanos and his minions disintegrated into
dust.
And we imagine any leftover Pym Particles
disintegrated, too.
If you're sitting around worrying about how
these mass-produced Pym Particles might create
more plot holes in the future, you can rest
easy tonight: all of those Pym Particles were
probably decimated the minute Iron Man put
the Infinity Stones to use.
Considering its size and scope, there were
bound to be at least a few plot holes in Avengers:
Endgame.
The time travel aspect of the film is kinda
difficult to unravel, and it's bound to affect
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the future,
too.
Here's one tidbit that somewhat clears things
up: Russo claims Endgame doesn't operate on
a closed time loop:
Words to live by!
After seeing Avengers: Endgame, fans are surely
wondering how the MCU will look and feel from
here on out.
While Russo was more than happy to spill details
about Endgame, he stayed quiet about what's
coming next.
What we do know: Spider-Man: Far From Home
picks up mere minutes after Avengers: Endgame.
The film will show us what's going on now
that half the population has snapped back
to life after spending five years in the void.
We imagine everyone's in a pretty good mood.
Well, almost everybody.
"You don't want any part of this."
The Spidey sequel almost certainly won't deal
with any time travel, and that's for the best.
For the sake of avoiding even more plot holes,
we sincerely hope Far From Home stays in the
here and now.
Who knows what'll happen next?
We'll be playing the waiting game until the
film hits theaters on July 5th, 2019.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.